then Sean William Scott good to see you
sir good to see you so you got the whole
goon team back-to-back got the gang back
together yeah what do you think works
about this movie that people just love
it can't get enough of this stuff you
know like somebody asked me the question
like because this as soon as the movie
came out like on Netflix yeah I had more
people come up to me about goon or at
least for the but I would say compared
to like American pilot America pie came
out and and beat had more like frat boy
drunken kind of college kids come up to
me but in this movie as soon as it came
out
you like people that you would not
normally think to go up to an actor to
see like the movie like they would come
up to me like I really really liked
doing tonight
were they missing teeth were they were
they I don't know there was like you
know women and guys that you know that
you just didn't think that would come up
to you but I I we never thought that the
first movie was gonna become kind of
like a cult hit but I think it's just
kind of a combination of it's funny it's
got a lot of heart and then I think
maybe the Doug Glatt character is like a
really sweet
good guy and you really root for him
right did you ever play hockey yourself
no never I mean I never dropped the puck
I grew up playing that sports my dad
played baseball basketball and football
right and in Minnesota in Minnesota yeah
so like the one you know sports movie
that I do is the sport that I didn't
play but you know I I think one of the
reasons why I didn't play hockey is I
remember when I was a kid I was I was a
dick I was like a real punk surprising
right and I was mouthing off to one of
like the older kids and in that warming
house you know and he's like why don't
we put you into goalie okay and then
like 10 older kids were just firing slap
shots on me I was like I'm good
I don't think I'm gonna be playing
hockey yeah even with all the padding on
yeah that was pretty much the end for me
so when you were there I mean the North
Stars had to exist right when you were
when you were growing Mississippi Dino
system yeah I remember I didn't watch a
lot of hockey bye remember him and what
a great name it great it's a great name
you have to be awesome with that name
correct
you know Mike Modano is I meant
okay you met my great guy yeah most hot
you see no hockey players are to a man
great guys it's true until some of them
get the skates on and put the sweater on
and then they become like you were when
you were growing up right exactly yeah
yeah they get the beards the hot beards
and then they just they just strew see
straight
sometimes yeah and you know what um so
in doing one we had Georges Laraque and
then in the sequel George Paris or like
a bunch of guys a bunch of like you know
stars but also like enforcers were in
the film sweetest guys ever right
there's like the nicest guys and but
stand in front of him and during during
a playoff hockey game my god they would
beat the crap out of you and I really
felt like like an [ __ ] you know trying
to play an enforcer and these guys are
like six five yeah I was like I'm doing
my best guys Sean William Scott here and
the Rich Eisen show did you watch like
slap shot I mean as a kid or anything
like that or it was I did cuz I love
movies sure and of course I love that
movie so what's your favorite sports
movie what do you got for me
piano name one would it be slap shot
would it be what are you well you know
what the first to think about is either
Rudy or the natural mm-hm
but I love slap shots you know who's
yours then the Hoosiers to me is the
best sports movie because gene Hackman's
in it and the best sports movies always
have like a father-son thing going on
and Dennis Hopper with one of the kids
on the team there's a father-son thing
going on there and the natural to me is
terrific yeah although I read the book
and it's completely different from the
book ending are you aware that it was
based on a book yeah Bernard Malamud
wrote a book and on the books spoiler
alert
for anybody was about the book Roy takes
the money what's in the book completely
different story exactly they couldn't do
Robert Redford's not gonna take the
money you've never taken that Redford no
the Bob Bob Redford I've never taken a
prize in the movie so yes okay so that's
with rudy' though as you could see I've
got the Michigan helmet right here on
the desk okay so now a Notre Dame guy
like Rudy I am rooting for him when he
gets on that field to blow out his
hamstring I would love to redo Rudy that
would be where Rudy finally gets his
shot oh my god exactly
that would be it another great ending
very different wouldn't maybe yeah we
should just hear quit your show quit
everything you're doing you and I are
gonna make films okay we're gonna go
back to the classics and we're just
gonna change the ending okay I think the
leg Rudy I really should die from a
pulled hamstring really if that doesn't
happen normally right but it's like it's
a bad hamstring pole and so yeah you're
just saying like if as long as I wish
ill will on him I should just go to the
max and and hope for his entire demise
to happen on the field but from a
hamstring injury yeah we can always do
test screening to see if it's too much
and maybe it's just he loses a leg so we
could we could figure out other great
sports movies here
well I can't Jimmy Chitwood like misses
the game-winner that's bad and then we
can't have miracle where the Soviets win
now can't have that the cornfield burns
down there's a fire nobody comes they
build it nobody shows the end the fuses
to have a catch with it yeah here's a
good one here's a good one they build
the cornfield and dead baseball players
come out but only those who didn't even
hit 200 in the major the worst the worst
yeah yeah even play yeah then they go
out on the field and like errors three
errors in one inning its unwatchable
baseball what do they what is that what
who whispers and that should be like
that should be like Chris Rock's voice
Gilbert Gilbert Godfried yes what does
he actually whisper in our version go
away see we have workshop this yeah
could we make a lot let's just keep
going you like this huh this is a great
idea Jerry Maguire Jerry Maguire yeah
there's no completion not even yeah
right you had me at you by when he lands
on his head he dies memory he falls on
his head not shooting but his character
is dead dead
no qualms you know it's just once he
lands his head and then he doesn't wake
up and they have all the shots of the
screen and the people are crowd and then
cut the black
should we get Cameron Crowe on the phone
and pitch it let's do this okay very
good Bad News Bears and all the breaking
training they actually let them play
yeah in the Astrodome they actually they
play and then just got the black Shawn
Williams Scott here on the Rich Eisen
show so goon lasted the enforcers you
got the gang back together a lot of fun
doing that is there any other sequel
possibility for anything else that's a
part of your Ashton Kutcher talk about a
dude where's my car yeah about that
anything like that I really don't think
there's an appetite for that okay the
real world right but I mean I would do
it for the title seriously dude where's
my car
that's what they're calling well its Oh
seriously dude that is my car and my
character gets killed and dies at the
end I would do that movie I do that
movie and I think we're gonna do like
another 40 American Pie movies yeah why
not right let's just do it until we all
die
you must yet you must get that all the
time still correct right I do like it
you know but not as often actually when
goon came around and people were
thinking me for another movies like
that's nice
mmm-hmm but still get a lot of stiffer
stuff but I love that character well I
wouldn't have a career if it wasn't for
that with
without that without Stifler and based
on you said that you were dick when you
were a kid so I myself your earlier
version of yourself no the truth is like
when I was in high school I was a really
sweet good kid like oh my you know we
were like mm all my friends were all
jocks and but we weren't like the dicks
we were actually really good kids but I
was more like Stifler when I was like
eight seven eight
a real a-hole really yeah it was a
monster
when you were eight you a lot of weird
stuff then I think that are safe for
work way that you say you were like
Stifler is an eight year old my mom
wouldn't appreciate anything fade to
black
we're all dead right down in there and
Liev Schreiber's and goon I'm yeah he's
awesome
he's the voice of HBO Sports he's the
voice of hard knocks yeah you know he's
such a great guy too but like he's he's
one of my favorite actors so to get a
chance to work with him twice now is it
was pretty wicked that's pretty cool
yeah he's really cool so Guin last of
the enforcers again starting on Friday
and select theaters on demand digital HD
and then on DVD October 3rd love having
here man come back anytime thank you
certainly and certainly since we're
gonna be in production together very
soon we're gonna make the big bucks oh
man that it truly that would be a I
would I would watch that Rudy that Rudy
I would work here you know dead cut to
black Sean Scott here are the choices
you just cut to black right here the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy